making those conversations better,
so bacteria can do things that we want them to do
better than they would be on their own.
Finally, I wanted to show you --
this is my gang at Princeton, New Jersey.
Everything I told you about was discovered by someone in that picture.
And I hope when you learn things, like about how the natural world works --
I just want to say that whenever you read something in the newspaper
or you hear some talk about something ridiculous in the natural world,
it was done by a child.
So science is done by that demographic.
All of those people are between 20 and 30 years old,
and they are the engine that drives scientific discovery in this country.
And it's a really lucky demographic to work with.
(Applause)
I keep getting older and older, and they're always the same age.
And it's just a crazy, delightful job.
And I want to thank you for inviting me here,
it's a big treat for me to get to come to this conference.
(Applause)
Thanks.